>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE MONTH-LONG SAGA TURNED
NIGHTMARE OF BRETT KAVANAUGH’S
SUPREME COURT CONFIRMATION
PROCESS FINALLY COMING TO A
CONCLUSION.
THE SENATE VOTED NARROWLY TODAY
TO MOVE THE DECISION TO THE
FLOOR.
THAT MEANS THE FINAL VOTE ON
THIS, ON KAVANAUGH, WILL TAKE
PLACE TOMORROW.
PROBABLY TOMORROW AFTERNOON.
THIS IS ALMOST OVER.
DEMOCRATS MADE ONE FINAL PUSH
AGAINST KAVANAUGH THIS AFTERNOON
SCREAMING PROTESTERS SWARMED THE
CAPITOL.
FAMOUS JOURNALISTS WENT CRAZY ON
TWITTER AND DIANNE FEINSTEIN,
THE 85-YEAR-OLD RANKING DEMOCRAT
ON THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE, SOMEONE LONG HOLDING
A REPUTATION FOR BEING
REASONABLE ABANDONED THAT
REPUTATION AND WENT ALL THE WAY.
SHE SUGGESTED THAT BRETT
KAVANAUGH ISN’T SIMPLY A BAD
NOMINEE OR A BAD JURIST, BUT
HE’S A VIOLENT AND DANGEROUS
PERSON.
HERE’S PART OF IT.
>> AT THE HEARING LAST WEEK, WE
SAW A MAN FILLED WITH ANGER AND
AGGRESSION.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH RAISED HIS
VOICE, HE INTERRUPTED SENATORS,
THIS BEHAVIOR REVEALED A
HOSTILITY AND BELLIGERENCE THAT
IS UNBECOMING OF SOMEONE SEEKING
TO BE ELEVATED TO THE UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT.
>> Tucker: LOCK THAT MAN UP!
FOR MUCH OF THE DAY, BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S FATE SEEMED
UNCERTAIN.
LISA MURKOWSKI OF ALASKA VOTED
WITH THE DEMOCRATS.
THEN SHE ISSUED A BIZARRE
STATEMENT IN WHICH SHE SAID THAT
KAVANAUGH IS A GOOD MAN, BUT
SHOULD NOT BE ON THE SUPREME
COURT.
IN OTHER WORDS, BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S WAS FALSELY ACCUSED
OF GANG RAPE AND THAT MEANS HE
CAN BE A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE.
KEEP IN MIND, THAT LISA
MURKOWSKI IS AN ACTUAL U.S.
SENATOR.
HARD TO BELIEVE BUT TRUE.
AND IN THE MID AFTERNOON,
SOMETHING REMARKABLE HAPPENED.
SOMETHING THAT VERY FEW
EXPECTED.
SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS OF MAINE,
ONE OF THE MOST LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS IN WASHINGTON AND
NOT FAMOUS FOR ORATORY, TOOK TO
THE FLOOR TO MOUNT A LOGICAL
DEFENSE OF KAVANAUGH’S
CHARACTER, ABILITY AND
NOMINATION.
HERE’S PART OF WHAT SHE SAID.
>> THE FACTS PRESENTED DO NOT
MEAN THAT PROFESSOR FORD WAS NOT
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THAT NIGHT OR
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THAT NIGHT ORAT SOME OTHER TIME, BUT THEY DO
AT SOME OTHER TIME, BUT THEY DO
LEAD ME TO CONCLUDE THAT THE
ALLEGATIONS FAILED TO MEET THE
MORE LIKELY THAN NOT STANDARD.
THESE CHARGES CAN FAIRLY PREVENT
THEREFORE, I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THESE CHARGES CAN FAIRLY PREVENTJUDGE KAVANAUGH FROM SERVING ON
JUDGE KAVANAUGH FROM SERVING ON
THE COURT.
MR. PRESIDENT, I WILL VOTE TO
CONFIRM JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: THIS WAS NOT AN
EMOTIONAL SPEECH.
FOR THAT REASON, IT WAS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM VIRTUALLY
ANYTHING WE’VE HEARD THE PAST
MONTH.
IT WAS AN ARGUMENT ROOTED IN
REASON.
IT HAD A HUGE EFFECT.
THE DAM BROKE ALMOST IMMEDIATELY
AFTER.
WEST VIRGINIA DEMOCRAT JOE
MANCHIN ANNOUNCED THAT HE TOO
WILL SUPPORT KAVANAUGH.
MANCHIN GIVES THE NOMINATIONS
THE NECESSARY 50 VOTES.
EVEN IF PROTESTERS FIND JEFF
FLAKE, THE NOMINATION WILL GO
THROUGH.
BARRING AN UNFORESEEN EVENT AND
THAT COULD HAPPEN, BUT IF IT
DOESN’T, BRETT KAVANAUGH WILL
BECOME A JUSTICE THIS WEEKEND.
FOR REPRESENTING HIS VOTERS IN
VIRGINIA THAT OVERWHELMINGLY
SUPPORT KAVANAUGH, THE YOUTH
RING OF THINKS PARTY RICHLY
DENOUNCED HIM IN THE HALLS OF
THE CAPITOL.
NOBODY TRIED TO STOP THEM OR
ASKED THEM TO BE QUIET BECAUSE
WE’RE GETTING USED TO MOB RULE
HERE.
WATCH.
[PROTESTERS CHANTING].
>> Tucker: THESE KINDS OF SCENES
ARE EVERYWHERE IN WASHINGTON
TONIGHT, WE’RE SAD TO TELL YOU.
THEIR OWN CASE.
THE LEFT HAS GIVEN UP ON MAKING
ACTIVISTS NO LONGER TRY TO
CONVINCE ANYONE OF ANYTHING.
INSTEAD, THEY SCREAM AND BULLY
AS A TACTIC THAT CAN BE
EFFECTIVE.
IT WORKED FOR THE MAFIA, FOR
EXAMPLE.
BUT THERE’S A COST TO IT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT’S ON
TELEVISION.
NORMAL PEOPLE FIND IT SCARY AND
UNREASONABLE BECAUSE THAT’S WHAT
IT IS, SCARY AND UNREASONABLE.
THE LEFT IS GOING TOO FAR.
AND IT’S ALIENATING EVEN LIBERAL
REPUBLICANS LIKE SUSAN COLLINS.
>> I AM THINKING IN PARTICULAR
NOT AT THE ALLEGATIONS RAISED BY
PROFESSOR FORD BUT OF THE
ALLEGATIONS THAT WHEN HE WAS A
TEENAGER, JUDGE KAVANAUGH
DRUGGED MULTIPLE GIRLS AND USED
THEIR WEAKENED STATE TO
FACILITATE GANG RAPE.
THIS OUTLANDISH ALLEGATION WAS
PUT FORTH WITHOUT ANY CREDIBLE
SUPPORTING EVIDENCE.
>> Tucker: THAT OUT LANDS DISH
STORY SARAH COLLINS IS REFERRING
TO WAS ALL OVER THE OTHER CABLE
CHANNELS FOR WEEKS.
IT WAS, OF COURSE, A FANTASY
PROMOTED BY STORMY DANIELS
ATTORNEY, THE WORLD’S CREEPIEST
PORN LAWYER, WHO IS A LEADING
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE IF THAT TELLS YOU
ANYTHING.
HE COULD BE PORN LAWYER LASHED
OUT ON COLLINS.
HE CALLED HER SPEECH ENTIRELY
DISINGENUOUS AND SHAMEFUL.
BY THIS POINT, EVEN DEMOCRATS
WERE STARTING TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE FREAK SHOW THAT THEY HAVE
UNLEASHED IS BEGINNING TO HURT
THEM.
KEN VOGEL AT THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" WONDERED ON TWITTER IF
THE CREEPY IMPORTANT LAWYER
COULD BE A DOUBLE AGENT, WORKING
FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
UNLIKELY BUT HE HELPED THEM.
IN THE FIELD, THEY NEVER GOT THE
MEMO.
ONE ABOUT TRYING TO SEE NONCRAZY
FOR THE SAKE OF SCARING THE
VOTERS.
MANY ON THE LEFT ATTACKED SUSAN
COLLINS FOR THE COLOR OF HER
SKIN.
"SENATOR SUSAN COLLINS IS THE
MOTHER AND GRANDMOTHER OF WHITE
WOMEN IN AMERICA THAT GAVE US A
DONALD TRUMP PRESIDENCY."
WHAT THAT MEANS, THEY’RE SAYING
IT.
AT G.Q., A WRITER WROTE THIS.
IF I DIE OF GETTING IN AN
ILLEGAL ABORTION, DROP MY BODY
OFF AFTER SENATOR COLLINS’ HOUSE
AND LOT IT ROT.
IF THERE’S ONE THING I LEARNED
IS WHAT THE ACTIVIST LEFT IS
REALLY THINGS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SCARED BY
WHAT THEY THINK.
ACTUALLY THE TERM "THINK" MAY BE
TOO GENEROUS.
A LOT OF WHAT WE’RE HEARING IS
NOT A PRODUCT OF THINKING.
IT A PRODUCT OF COORDINATED
INSTRUCTIONS HANDED DOWN FROM ON
HIGH AND DUTIFULLY REPEATED BY
ANGRY CHILDREN.
LIBERALS ARE PARTY PEOPLE.
THEY DO EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
TOLD.
WATCH THIS SCENE TODAY FROM
CAPITOL HILL WHICH SAYS IT ALL.
>> LET’S GO WATCH THE VOTE.
>> LET’S DO WATCH THE VOTE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> Tucker: REPEAT AFTER ME!
LIKE THE LITTLE ROBOTS THEY ARE,
THEY DO.
DURING HER SPEECH, SUSAN COLLINS
NOTED THAT SUPREME COURT
NOMINATION BATTLES HAVE BEEN
STEADILY ANGRIER AND MORE
VICIOUS OVER THE COURSE OF 30
YEARS.
SHE SAYS SHE HOPES WHAT HAPPENED
TO BRETT KAVANAUGH IS ROCK
BOTTOM AND GETS BETTER FROM
HERE.
OF COURSE, WE AND A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE HOPE SHE’S RIGHT.
WE WORRY THAT SHE ISN’T.
THE EFFORT TO DESTROYED BRETT
KAVANAUGH’S LIFE FAILED,
APPARENTLY.
BUT ONLY BARELY.
NOBODY IMPORTANT SEEMS TO REGRET
WHAT HAPPENED TO HIM.
NORMS LIKE THE PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE AND BASIC FAIRNESS,
THE ONES THIS COUNTRY IS BUILT
ON, REMAIN INTACT BUT THEY’VE
BEEN DAMAGED.
THEY MAY CRUMBLE IF THEY’RE
ATTACKED A AGAIN.
WILL THEY BE?
THAT DEPENDS ON VOTERS.
IF VOTERS REWARD MOB JUSTICE IN
NOVEMBER, THE SCREAMING ROBOTS
YOU SAW ON THE SCREEN, WE’RE
GOING TO GET MORE OF US BECAUSE
THAT’S THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS.
IF VOTERS REJECT IT, THE
DEMOCRATS MAY RETHINK THE
STRATEGY AND GET BACK TO ARGUING
ON BEHALF OF WHAT THEY SAY THEY
BELIEVE.
WHICH WOULD BE A MASSIVE
IMPROVEMENT OVER SENDING OUT
THEIR YOUTH WING TO SCREAM AT